a summer of record-breaking heat is
drying up rivers across europe around
half the continent is facing an
unprecedented drought shipping companies
in germany are preparing for the worst
as levels on the river rhine drop to
critical levels
authorities say many vessels will be
unable to navigate the key shipping
route if the water drops much lower
scientists warn climate change will lead
to even more frequent periods of extreme
heat and drought
dw samantha baker is at the rhine in
cologne sam just how bad is it where you
are
the water levels here are extremely low
uh they're almost approaching record
levels here in cologne so you can see
around me
the the banks here are creeping into the
middle of the river i mean they're
really expanding from from where the
water levels were earlier this summer
uh so like i said this is reaching
almost near record lows and it's
affecting shipping as you mentioned so
if the water is not a meter and a half
high
these large ships can't navigate the
rhine uh which means they have to carry
less goods as little as 25 percent of
what they were planning to carry and
that leads to delays and shipping and
increased costs unfortunately this
situation isn't uh forecast to change
anytime soon those those water levels
aren't set to rise anytime soon sam
normally water levels only begin to drop
from this time of year how is it managed
to get
is so bad so early
well climate change is certainly having
an impact here on the drought across
europe really
so we've seen prolonged periods of high
temperatures this summer and not very
much rainfall in the past few weeks so
that is just making the problem worse
and worse
so
you know
this this impact is making droughts in
general
more intense more frequent more severe
and and it's leading to these really low
water levels not only here on the rhine
but also on the loire in france on the
po river in italy on the danube really
across the continent
authorities say shipping on the river
ryan where you are might soon come to a
standstill what would be the economic
impact of that
yeah so that will certainly
impact businesses
here in germany as well as a few other
countries
most of germany's goods are shipped on
the rhine so it's going to have a big
impact in 2008 the last time
that uh water levels got this low uh it
impacted germany's gdp by 0.4 percent uh
businesses are a little bit more
prepared this time because they had that
record year in
2018 um
but you know it's it's to be seen
usually these record lows come closer to
october so we've still got a ways to go
in the season
so
what can be done
so
because this drought is made worse by
climate change the main thing is
reducing
our greenhouse gas emissions and that
means stop using fossil fuels now it's
perhaps a bit ironic that many of the
ships that go up and down this river
behind me are carrying things like coal
heating oil and diesel and burning those
fossil fuels is making
the problem of climate change worse
which is making it harder for them to
navigate this river due to low water
levels and due to this drought
so that's the main thing to be done in
the long term
term
some of these companies
you know may need to find other ways to
move their goods
if they can't get up and down the rhine
dw samantha baker in cologne thank you
well climate scientists say human
activities have contributed to an
increasingly warm planet
dw reporter william bluecroft has an
overview of the extreme heat
catastrophic drought and record
wildfires disrupting this european
summer
the whole world is getting hotter but
data show europe is outpacing the global
average and that's leading to conditions
rarely seen in an otherwise temperate
part of the world let's start with those
wildfires that several european
countries are battling now this year has
already been
a record number of total fires since the
european union started keeping track in
2006. now here we can see those blazers
have so far burned
660 000 hectares of land and if we
compare it to the average to this point
so far in the year it's three and a half
times more than the average
over all of those years now what is 660
000 hectares let's put that in
perspective that area is bigger than all
of the city of istanbul and the fire
season is not over yet so what's making
it so bad fire officials are pointing to
extreme drought and high temperatures
which are only getting hotter and it's
not just about hot weather or one hot
summer it's about a trend we can look at
germany as just an example germany is of
course a fairly cool northern european
country you can see here average summer
temperatures in german between 1960 and
now
2022 and yes of course there are some
cooler years but the trend is
unmistakable it's going up it's getting
warmer and warmer and warmer with every
year starting in 1960 with a temperature
of just under 16 degrees celsius and
this year not yet over we don't quite
know but we may be reaching almost 19
degrees celsius with that high point
back in 2003 at 19.67 degrees celsius
and remember these are just averages
these also include
lows in the night time heat waves hot
days and tropical nights are all on the
rise
now that has health consequences for
people living in these more frequent and
more intense conditions because the
human body can't cool off an
infrastructure that's made for a
temperate zone like northern europe
can't cope but there's knock-on effects
as well for all around the world higher
temperatures and less water can reduce
economic productivity destroy
agriculture and make trade more
difficult and expensive and that makes
climate change anywhere a problem for
everyone everywhere
william there the netherlands which
borders germany is normally one of the
wettest countries in europe but this
summer it's also battling a prolonged
drought and water shortages with just
about a third of its land below sea
level the netherlands is especially
vulnerable to climate change and is now
being forced to adapt fast
kettle coming to a water hole
at a dried-out reservoir just outside
the dutch town of daventer it's a very
dry season now and you can see the the
water level is very very low
this canal would normally be bringing
water into one of the netherlands
biggest rivers we are the at the bottom
of the sky big
normally there's uh water over here but
now you can see it's all it's all gone
you can see a little bit of water over
there a few meters upstream but this is
all gone and that's the the river isil
you can see
how low it's
wine end is responsible for the upkeep
of the dike system in this region and
the extreme heat is not only drying out
the waterways but also endangering his
levees
yeah this would be all covered with
grass right now you can see it's
it's all dirt
so dry now
you need the grass cover because it's
erosion blankets
top of levy
yeah you can see what the future would
look like if it stays there's better
the dike needs water for it to stay safe
and vinant has to prepare for the
changing conditions
we look what plants
can
be better at the drought with longer
routes you want to learn from southern
parts parts of europe too you have to
learn from it
moving 90 kilometers westward on the
outskirts of the city of utrecht the
picture seems quite different
this pumping station is called the arm
water the supplier and it's part of the
climate adaptation system that we use to
get sweet water to the west of the
netherlands
but with the rhine already running at
extremely low levels it looks to be
helping one neighbor at the expense of
another nature agriculture and also the
dikes needs the water from the rhine
river
because if this pump stops working salt
water from the sea will push into the
coastal waterways
geron is looking at a complete reversal
of dutch water management the history of
the netherlands is a history of flood
defense
and that is how the dutch built the
netherlands
especially the westland restaurant part
you know below the sea level but we also
now have to prepare for more drought and
more warmth and more heat
however central water distribution is of
little help on the reuters family farm
normally the cows
all day walk outside and
take the grass outside but now there's
nothing growing so
and cows have to eat something so they
stay inside and eat
all the grass from last year
and with his corn fields in his sorry
state farmer willem yan has little hope
they can grow enough feed
when there's no rain the strays out
nothing grows
hopefully to the rain we will hope that
it will rain but the way it goes on the
forecast is expecting yet more dry and
hot weather
i'm joined now from delft in the
netherlands by bart von derhawk he's a
climate researcher at the deltarus
institute professor we heard it there in
our report the forecast is not good
how damaging do you think this hot dry
summer will be to the netherlands
well this is indeed something we are not
very
used to i mean you heard from the video
just before that we are a country that
is prepared for flooding and we sort of
have a heroic story about our country
that we we have defended ourselves
against the sea and the rivers
but this is a drought situation that is
of course yeah uh reaching us more and
more often with with a change in climate
but
we need to uh
increasingly get used to it and then so
we really need to to adjust ourselves to
this kind of situation for sure
what would be the uh consequences though
if uh the dutch don't uh adapt in time
well that that actually is no option
because no one can live without water so
we'll we'll adapt in one way or another
and and you know there is we have had
dry years for sure and we are currently
in this year we are not in in a record
year even
1976 is still say
the most prominent
drought year that we have experienced in
modern history
but of course our society has developed
as well since then our population has
grown economy has grown so we are
probably a bit more sensitive to say so
these kind of conditions but again 2018
also was a year that was really yeah
another kind of wave cop call and also
because we had a sequence of dry years
also 2019 and 20 were relatively dry in
in a growing season
and that made us aware that this is
something to stay and something to
prepare for and
yeah and since then we have implemented
quite a few measures
like uh
more water retention we've elaborated on
on the way we manage our fresh water
reservoirs we have a big lake called
lake isil which is
covering uh
15 percent of the netherlands say to the
north and when we manage it in order to
have sufficient amount of water
we also have a lot of attention paying
paid currently to
you know uh keeping water in the domain
that that uh
the whole domain of
many of the areas were designed to to
get rid of the water and we drained
areas to convert it into agricultural
land but now we realize we we need to
keep the water in so we've we've changed
a lot of the natural flows and
the water management in order to to have
higher water levels throughout the year
etc etc so there's so many adaptation
actions
ongoing and and still to come
so no adaptation is not an option at all
uh some of those solutions or all of
those solution solutions that other
countries can adapt
sorry i couldn't get question yes are
those solutions that you just listed off
uh solutions that other countries can
adapt to uh
well yes and no i think um
do we have a a good tradition in water
management and that is both on the the
technical side says say about the
infrastructure but also on the
governance side there's a lot of
adaptation actually that is going about
who is actually responsible for which
part of the whole system and also the
adjustment between different government
layers and interactions with with the
users of the water that's also
a thing that has evolved over time
but i think we can also learn from from
other countries on our side as i said
this is this is not a
a usual situation this is not something
we are really experienced to
and so and there's other countries even
within europe where where i say climate
is a bit different and for instance in
spain we have a much a very different
say
annual cycle of rainfall and we know for
sure that in in in large parts of the
summer season there is no water at all
so you need to deal a lot on that water
management already early in the year
when there is still water
and and and and there the the
the the negotiation process on who gets
which part of the water of course takes
place at the moment that that you still
can take some action which is more like
in in early spring at time
and
those are
and and also in in all kinds of say more
infrastructural arrangement about how to
conserve water how to maintain its
quality how to uh
the
development of
living with water like development of
housing on water or
agriculture that is more water resistant
whatever
those are kinds of practices that we
definitely learn from other countries i
would say can i just ask you briefly
though how the problems here in europe
caused by extreme heat compared to other
parts of the world
well yes that's that's a good question i
i've been involved in the latest ipcc
climate change assessment um in the in
the physical report that was released
last uh last year in august
and there we
we get a global picture of what climate
change is doing and
for sure
europe is uh is is exposed to
increasingly to also drought problems
for sure the mediterranean area is is
really a hot spot for this but we also
see at our say mid-latitudes where
germany and the netherlands are the the
risk of these kinds of events is
increasing so this all what we are
seeing now sort of fits the picture
but i'm really you know sometimes
astonished by the pictures i see from
for instance the middle east or
countries like iraq or the
in china currently we have a nine week
long heat wave with with
days and days or even weeks and weeks
where regions the temperature
is exceeding 35 40 degrees during time
and that is that is getting incredibly
difficult to yeah
almost to survive in any climate like
that in the south of iraq
basra i i was told the other day that
that we have 52 degrees centigrade on
midday and it's
cooling to not cooler than 35 degrees in
in during night time so there's no way
people can recover well that is
definitely it definitely sounds like a
global phenomenon that's for sure but
from the herk we'll have to leave it
there thank you very much really really
interesting stuff
okay thank you bye-bye
well those low water levels across
europe are also making it harder to cool
power stations in france it's a creating
a particular headache for the country's
nuclear power industry
nuclear reactors produce around 70
percent of the country's power and many
of those reactors depend on huge
quantities of water from nearby rivers
to cool them down
strict rules aim to protect aquatic life
govern how much hot water can be
re-released downstream but due to
france's current energy crunch many
nuclear stations have received special
permits to keep running something that's
making environmentalists worried dw's
lisa lewis reports now from southwestern
france
france has been baking and temperatures
of up to 40 degrees for months now
that is putting french nuclear plants
under strain authorities are having to
bend the rules for about a fifth of them
just to keep them running
usually nuclear power plant operators
are only allowed to discharge their
cooling water into rivers like the
garonne if the river's temperature
is under a certain limit that is to
protect the local flora and fauna
currently though authorities have
suspended that rule at certain reactors
like the goldfest plant here behind me
they say it's the only way to guarantee
france's power supply
but these environmental activists are
outraged that rules are being suspended
for nuclear power plants when river
systems are already under stress in the
heat and drought
they say warming them up even more is
disastrous
it's a catastrophe for plants and fish
some of them die which has ripple
effects throughout the whole food chain
when for example there are no micro
algae certain small fish die that are
normally food for bigger fish
plus warmer water contains more bacteria
in order to make it potable we have to
add a lot of chemicals which people then
drink
but with half of all reactors closed for
maintenance france desperately needs the
ones that are running to keep going
power company edf which declined our
request for an interview has called the
situation extraordinary
and yet the current issues don't seem to
be an existential problem for french
nuclear power the government is about to
nationalize edf and plans to build new
reactors this energy expert says betting
heavily on nuclear flow energy is not a
good strategy especially in the short
run
[Music]
new nuclear plants can't be commissioned
in the short term as their technology is
not ready yet renewables are different
they have become cheaper and cheaper
over the past few years and could be
deployed immediately across the country
neighboring countries will be watching
closely until now france has been
europe's biggest net energy exporter
this year though the country will have
to import more electricity than it's
exporting
let's get some analysis i'm joined by
professor thorsten wagner he's a water
expert from the university of potsdam
professor how worried are you about the
current low river water levels we are
seeing across europe
well we see another stress test to the
water system in europe
and we
currently find all the the problem
points we've seen some in 2018 already
but
as your report already said then
the dry points the low points in the
rivers were later in the year in october
and now they're even earlier
and
we might see
problems with shipping which is already
reduced and might even come to hold in
parts of germany and parts of europe
now the drought is having a serious
impact on
various industries you mentioned
shipping there which ones are struggling
the most it's not just shipping is it
no it varies across europe we
see that in spain in portugal in italy
agriculture
is is in huge trouble we see that in
france
energy production is in trouble because
it needs water from the rivers for
cooling and it can't take enough to
produce energy in germany we see
partially the shipping
in the uk we see groundwater levels
falling
so it's all across europe and depending
on
where water is used most in in different
countries we see the problem areas occur
so how long do you see this drought to
go on
well it will last a bit longer we will
have
thunderstorms and small periods of rain
but that is not going to be enough to
wetten up the soil so that it can even
receive really the water that the soil
needs and that the groundwater needs
and we probably are into september when
at least the forecast at the moment
suggests that it might become more
normal conditions again
and then we will
look for prolonged periods of rain to
recover the system
now what is the role of climate change
in the extreme dry and hot season we are
seeing this summer
well it's very clear that with
increasing climate change
we will see increasing occurrence of
these extremes
dry more intense periods more regular
periods of dry
summers
often or we we hope that they will be
balanced a little bit by wetter winters
but if the winters are also dry as we've
seen now then we can see how troublesome
that is and what we really see is how
what
1.5 degrees or some
number of climate change that is maybe a
bit abstract for people what that
actually means for us
through these kinds of droughts
now climate change fighting climate
change of course is a very very
long-term game
in the short term what can be done to
help countries across europe
well this this kind of stress test to
the system that we see right now tells
us
how quickly certain areas get into
trouble farming we've started talking
about the po river a few weeks ago where
farming
is very water intensive with rice and
uses surface water so that's very
fragile we have other areas that need a
prolonged more prolonged period of
drought before they get into trouble
what we need to
see now is where we can adapt either to
different crops where we can buffer the
system maybe for shorter or longer
periods for reservoirs
and where we really have to change our
approach and the shipping is one good
example because even a few years ago
people realized how fragile it actually
is
and started changing the system because
certain goods could only be transported
by
river and we see what kind of impact
that has on the gdp as your report said
professor tost wagner thank you very
much
thank you